jeromy's shop ESPN reporter sports
writer author east 60 host co-director
of 30 for 30 documentary 42 to 1 and the
odds were 42 to 1 the Buster Douglas was
going to beat Mike Tyson that was back
in 1994 the heavyweight championship and
you can see the world premiere next
Tuesday that'll be December 11th at 9:00
Eastern on ESPN
it's co-directed by Jeremy eight-time
Emmy Award winner 11 it's 11 trust
Wikipedia I mean I've got an official
bio dan knows they hand out those things
like well I got him his door stoppers I
use him like when I'm cooking hot dogs
with the kids I'll put hot dogs a bottle
opener there it's true it's true people
in the business know how little it means
we really really care well you care
because other people care yes right but
we were nominated this show believe it
or not was was nominated know that yep
we acted like we were up against Sports
Center okay so we acted it was really
important leading up to it and then when
we lost and then we acted like it didn't
mean anything
of course you know it's one of those
that you'd rather win than lose but if
you lose it's easy to diminish the
significance of the award I just wanna
wake I'm okay with being nominated and
losing you are yeah well I mean I've
seen you nominated a lot yeah yeah you
know what it's just Costas is the
Michael Jordan of sports casters and I'm
sort of Patrick Ewing or Charles Barkley
or you know I it's it's a tough it's a
tough category shouldn't they do
something Ward after Bob Costas at this
point well I think he's still active so
I mean it's like you want it don't you
it shouldn't there be a rule like you
got to be retired for six years before
they name the award after you
they named the writing award after my
father but he was already dead and
Bobby's Bobby's a lot of it Bob is a lot
easier you know on that one
one that award though yeah and Ernie
Johnson's won that award there there
have been some cracks over the years
although bigger upset Bob dominated that
lot Lester Douglas I know Bob beat me
this past right so Buster Douglas
against Mike Tyson or us against Bob
Costas eruption well I think if it had
gone you know to the oddsmakers in Vegas
I think you were probably closer to like
a twenty seven twenty eight to one okay
I don't think forty 22 to me that's just
off the top of my head but you've won
the award and you've won it multiple
times yes but you and you have a rivalry
with Bob Lee so was buried deep was his
Bob he would have been a bigger upset I
feel well you know it's it for a long
time I think Bob refused to allow
himself to be entered into the category
yeah but that means you just don't want
to have somebody else I you know I
wouldn't want to speak for Bob okay in
this situation but I understand that I
understand that but I you know if you
say I don't want to be nominated you
just don't want to be nominated and lose
then well I don't think that was the
case with General William Sherman for
instance when he said if nominated I
will not run if elected I will not serve
there was a very strong chance if he had
run he would have been nominated and he
would have won the presidential election
if he had run it anytime during the
1880s but so I don't think it's
necessarily follows that you always are
just deflecting I didn't mind getting
nominated like I felt bad if I didn't I
felt worse if I didn't get nominated
then if I didn't win I you know I I do
host this show with Bob every Sunday and
I take it personally they don't even
submit me about being nominated I don't
even get a submission from the network
you know you know at ESPN we've got 500
hoes yeah I think there's like a list
Wow you know maybe they're like 10
people who are in the discussion then
they're like 5 people they consider
submitting but each submission cost like
200 bucks they don't want to waste the
money on somebody like me well just say
you'll you'll pone
up to 200 you know it's not worth that
you want but when da Reno Co gets
nominated and you don't that's when you
really get upset I'm a legendary no cos
I did not say that I not not out on the
record not not only not it's 42 to 1 and
it's Mike Tyson and Buster Douglas this
was 1990 so I think I got to the
mothership I'd been there a year I think
I got there in 1980 I knew you when you
were at CNN but I got I got there and I
think Eric Clemens went to told you a
joke yes here's one of the handful of
Americans were sent to Japan to cover
the fun because nobody thought they just
thought that this was just working on
yeah that he was you know Tyson was
going to win it and win it easily so why
send somebody all the way to Japan you
know when I started watching this in and
I'm refreshing my memory and I told
these guys I interviewed Tyson in 1986
he was on the cover of Sports
Illustrated he was kid dynamite and he
was he was rough around the edges but he
there was something about that roughness
that you know we were attracted to we
liked the way that he went into the ring
there was no cape there was no robe
there was no fanfare
you know black shoes here I go I'm a
knock you out and I got to get out of
here and then we just thought that this
was a foregone conclusion
how did Buster Douglas happen so I mean
that's what the docs really about and
it's it's really about the fact that the
story is people think they understand it
is not the story Buster Douglas did not
get lucky it wasn't a fluke
he was a guy with tremendous town and
tremendous potential who up until that
point when he fought that fighter in
February 11 1990 in Tokyo had never
brought all of his talents to bear and
so you know it's not a lucky punch
he beats Mike Tyson around the ring for
10 rounds he dominates the fight other
than the 8th round where he gets knocked
down he probably wins all of the other
rounds this was a situation
which someone with tremendous a talent
tremendous ability who hadn't
necessarily tapped his full potential
prior to that point somehow did it under
these circumstances when the stakes were
highest when it mattered most 23 days
after the death of his mother who was
the most important person in his world
and he rose to the occasion in a way no
one expected no one could have possibly
foreseen a fashion's this this
transcendent upset which i don't think
has ever really been appreciated for how
remarkable it was he was probably the
third best fighter in his own family his
dad was a fighter his mom was tough he
might have been the third best fighter
but when you watch the fight you realize
he is the better boxer
I always thought and I've said this
before that Tyson's maybe the most
overrated fighter in history because
once you got him past the third round he
got nervous because then you were going
to you know but he stuns Douglas he you
know he was loading up for one punch
right and you had to stay away from the
one punch Douglas gets up and as you
point out in the thirty four thirty
maybe it was 12 seconds for him to rise
but he did get up he's you can you could
see him he gets knocked down he gets hit
by a tremendous uppercut he he gets
knocked out he's on the canvas he slams
his fist he's not out of it he knows
exactly where he is he's angry that he
allows you angry that he allowed to
happen because he was caught for a
moment admiring his own work he was so
completely in control that he lost a
little bit of focus and despite the
entreaties of his corner did not stay
alert and he got hit by the uppercut but
you could see him he's doing exactly
what you're supposed to do he's
following the referees count and he just
beats the count because that's what
you're supposed to do you're supposed to
take your time and he gets up the eighth
round ends and then the ninth round
ensues and it's one of the great rounds
in the annals of hell yeah and you have
you have analysts there you have writers
who said that that ninth round might
have been the best round on boxing
history
it's unbelieving and the 10th round you
can see Buster Douglas
he's he has gotten his confidence back
and he just and he's even describing it
he's gone thump-thump thump-thump like
he knew that it's coming it's coming
it's coming
boom he catches Tyson he'd been chopping
at him you know for 10 rounds wearing
him down remember Mike's got a huge his
eyes swollen nearly shut I think it was
his left eye but the fact that they
didn't bring the proper medical
equipment because they didn't think
Tyson was gonna get hurt thought it was
gonna be over and two rounds they put a
plastic glove with ice in it and put it
on Tyson's eyes it's a there had been a
spoon thought for a long time that it
was not a rubber glove but in fact a
condom but in fact that wasn't true
aaron snowell who was in Tyson's Corner
for that fight said it was a rubber
glove but they did not have an ends well
of course I've talked to Mike about this
over the years too he says that would
have made any difference whatsoever that
buster was did he I think there was a
that Tyson wasn't really taking care of
himself leading into that fight that he
sort of was drilling it in is that fair
I it's totally fair I think Buckner was
still the better boxer that night
there's no doubt he was the better boxer
that night there's no doubt that Buster
had he's a better athlete than Mike
Tyson as physically as a presence he's a
much bigger man yeah six foot four as
opposed to five nine five ten
yeah weighed him by about eight or nine
pounds in that fight well I mean Tyson
couldn't get to him at all and uh look I
I think it's one of those situations
Buster Douglas at his absolute best
which we did not see very often arguably
only in this one fight Buster Douglas at
his absolute best against Mike Tyson at
his absolute best that's even money
that's not forty two to one we just at
that point had elevated Mike Tyson to
this pedestal where he was considered
legitimately by learning boxing people
the greatest fighter who'd ever walked
the face of the planet based on you know
five years of professional work did
anybody call this up son the only person
who predicted it he's in the film but we
don't get into the prediction
is Tim Mae from the Columbus Dispatch
who'd covered Buster literally from his
first professional fight and Buster from
Columbus Buster from Columbus so I think
Tim a really did think that he was going
to win - may the great sports around
Columbus still there just announced his
retirement last week but it's discounted
a little bit by some people because he
is the hometown guy
what if Tyson doesn't lose that fight
different world it's certainly he goes
on to fight Evander Holyfield later that
year who knows what happens in that
situation we know that Holyfield would
beat him in 96 and then beat him in 97
with the the bite
you know the entire it you know that's
what's different about boxing - unlike
every other sport everything is
contingent upon the last title fight
that you know it's not like golf or
tennis where no matter what you've got
the Masters next year in the PGA this
everything is a domino effect and who
knows what would happen if Mike wins
that fight does somebody eventually
figure out the key is standing up to him
bullying him back getting physical with
him working the jab obviously eventually
everybody everybody except Marciano and
Mayweather at some point you know meets
that end but it could have been years
and years and years I mean he was that's
one of the things in the film that was
fun going back and exploring where Mike
Tyson was in the cultural from a minute
that point and there was nobody close
yeah you were part of that I mean you
saw that up close I mean he was the most
famous popular athlete on the planet and
there's this kind of innocence about it
at that point like you see that Good
Morning America interview that we show a
clip from where you know it's you think
it's mr. Rogers not Mike Tyson he's
still trying to figure out exactly who
he is
when I interviewed him in the Catskills
at custom Otto's house and he came down
with a pair of sunglasses on that were
reminiscent of Jim McMahon's
so he had these funky shades on right
and I go hey you're looking like Jim
McMahon yes no he had no idea who boxers
that it's changed a little bit because
now in this country at least a lot of
our boxers the heavyweights anyway are
guys who did not succeed in other sports
and they've gone into boxing afterwards
but but in the old days that even the
Tyson days boxing is so singular the
boxers are so laser focused everything
else seems to them like a game I've
known a lot who don't pay any attention
to other sports they don't even know
what other sports are about and Buster
didn't do much after that you know he
had us know so Buster got paid a lot in
the he got anything is no paycheck at
that time in the history of sports after
that fight 24 million we get paid for
the Tyson fight 1.2 okay and then he got
9 million in any lost to Holyfield
Holyfield
eight months later I think Holyfield is
underrated I in the history of the sport
I think Evander Holyfield is one who he
jumped up in weight maybe 20 the Tyson
fight yeah the both but I mean he I
think look that heavyweight mix in the
90s which at the time we didn't really
appreciate you know you've got Riddick
Bowe who had tremendous skills and was
enormous and Lennox Lewis and Evander
Holyfield and Mike Tyson and you know
for one day at least you know Buster
Douglas and a few other guys in that mix
it was a tremendous mix and the
round-robin of those tournaments I mean
the fact that Lennox Lewis and Riddick
Bowe never fought his pros I mean that's
a discredit to this embarrassing Lewis
and Tyson don't fight until they're
their mid-30s Lewis I think yes I
wouldn't if Tyson won it against my the
point is that these things didn't happen
and they should have happened but yes
with Holyfield remember those those bow
fights I mean those were huge events
outdoors but holy wasn't a big guy from
the standpoint of no in Riddick Bowe you
know if you're gonna look at the whole
trilogy Riddick Bowe dominates him yeah
and then Riddick Bowe you know goes off
and joins the marine and the crazy stuff
happens you know there's always the
posit I'm having weird flashbacks though
right now Dan because I'm remembering
the first time I was ever live on
SportsCenter you were hosting oh and I
was covering the Yankees Rangers
Division Series in 1996 I was so scared
so scared to be a live TV for the first
time especially talking to you and I've
got John Burkett sitting next to me
standing next to me and he had just won
the game for the Rangers and I said I
said - I'm so nervous John if I ask you
a question I'm gonna ask you a question
now please give me a long answer because
I don't know if I could spit out a
second question he's like really really
I'm like really
he gave the longest answer in the hiss I
will always love John Burton not only a
300 bowler that's great he'd the longest
answer in the history sports are because
I was too nervous to talk to Dan Patrick
live on TV I'm Jeremy Shappy sp but you
okay who has a longer delivery you or
mark Schwartz see I I think I've
adjusted over the years Rinaldi's gone a
little too long to that we're stretching
it out a little bit and milking and
piano music here oh you know sometimes
it strings and kinda delivery you know
doing that kind of storytelling
obviously then then highlight driven
stuff ah
look I'm not blowing smoke I got to say
the first day I was ever at ESPN working
for the company it was the fall of 93 I
walked in there I was doing a piece and
it was the old newsroom and you were
doing some Sunday it was a Sunday night
you were doing some highlight and you I
don't think you even had a shot sheet in
front of you and you popped it into one
of the old decks it was a Niners game
and it was flawless I mean nobody could
do that the way that you did it it it
scared me because I'm like geez I want
to do this I can never do that so I'm
like I'll do you know feature pieces
with long deliveries and win it and when
eleven ladee not 8:11 notice the 34 30
is 42 to 1 Buster Douglas Mike Tyson
1990 heavyweight championship of the
world you can see it Tuesday December
11th at 9:00 Eastern on the mothership
great to see you thank you thank you
buddy
he's Jeremy shap for more Dan Patrick
show to the audience
2:39 on directv or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]